مع تحضير كييف لهجوم الربيع واستعداد
موسكو له يتوقع ان يزج البلدان الالاف من
الجنود الجدد في جبهات القتال عبر قوانين
مشدده لتجنيدهم في روسيا سارع البرلمان
لاصدار تشريعات جعلت من الصعب على الروس
مراوغه التجنيد او مغادره البلاد وفي
اوكرانيا وافقت الحكومه على قواعد تسمح
لمراكز التجنيد بارسال استدعاءات في اي
مكان في البلاد بعدما كانت ترسل الى
عناوينهم المسجله فقط تنص التشريعات
الروسيه الجديده على ارسال الاستدعاء
رقميا او عبر البريد حيث سيعتبر الاشعار
مستلما بعد اسبوع من ارساله سواء تم
استلامه بالفعل ام لا وبمجرد انقضاء
المهله يحضر على المجلد مغادره البلاد ومن
لا يحضر في غضون 20 يوما يحضر عليه قياده
السيارات والحصول على قروض وشراء او بيع
او تاج ير اي ممتلكات بعقود طويله
التغييرات الروسيه تنطبق على كل من
التعبئه للجبهه الاوكرانيه والتجنيد
الاجباري كما سيتم انشاء سجل الكتروني
للاشخاص المطلوبين لاكمال الخدمه العسكريه
التغييرات تهدف الى تحسين نظام التسجيل
العسكري وليس لها علاقه بالتعبئه الكرملين
لا يعتقد ان التغييرات ستسبب حاله من
الذعر وموجه جديده من الهجره
وبينما تنفي موسكو ربط التشريعات الجديده
بالتعبئه تقول وثائق المخابرات الامريكيه
ان 43 الف جنديا روسيا قتلوا بينما قتل ما
يصل الى
17,500 جندي اوكراني تقول المعلومات ان
نصف مليون روسي فرو من البلاد منذ بدء
الحرب في اوكرانيا معظمهم من الرجال في سن
القتال وهو امر يطرح تساؤلا جديدا كم سيفر
بعد هذه التشريعات وهل بامكانهم الفرار
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتق
ارير الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات